Oh tesoro come stai Eh il cucciolo è con
la nonna Sì guarda te lo faccio vedere
eh gli nanetti sono i miei ma i colori
sono quelli del papà sì sì va già il
nido Guarda Un angelo non fa storie si
diverte non piange mi fanno solo
complimenti Eh ma il segreto sai qual è
la mia Bisogna abituarli fin da subito a
staccarsi dalla mamma se no non se ne
esce se no non se ne esce più Pensa che
mia cognata fa tutto con la bambina
nella fascia Sì e poi ti dice no quando
la metto giù in macchina Piange ma va
Volevo dire se la tieni anche in casa
con la fascia è normale Sono bambini
Pensa che l'altra sera non vaccino con
questa coppia di amici allora il mio
cucciolo ha detto Io voglio mangiare la
pasta col granchio così anche l'altro
bimbo ha detto mamma la voglio anch'io
la mamma del bimbo ha deciso che lui non
la poteva mangiare no non la può
mangiare perché so che non gli piace ma
l'ha mai provata no mi ha detto ma
come perché non gli piace se non l'ha
mai provata Ma guarda ma a Lucia poi per
compensare Cosa fa gli da latte in
polvere Ma guarda ma robe da pazzi
proprio